tonight damning new details continue to
emerge surrounding joe biden's family
corruption scandals
documents text emails eyewitness
accounts
are now painting what is a very corrupt
and a very ugly picture
and of course it is well documented the
fact that biden's son
zero experience hunter his brother jim
received
millions and millions of dollars from
sketchy foreign nationals cashing in on
then vice president
biden and that would be ukrainian
oligarchs russian oligarchs
uh kazakh oligarchs chinese nationals
bank of china you name it they were
making money
and all to buy influence and now thanks
to
what are troves of new evidence it is
becoming increasingly clear
joe biden himself played a critical role
in the sketchy payouts
offering special access in exchange for
sweetheart
business deals millions for his family
and according to a former biden business
partner
tony babalinsky joe biden not only knew
about the pay for play schemes but was a
integral part of the process and it's
important to point out that so far
no one has directly refuted mr
bobolinsky's claims not
joe biden not hunter biden not jim biden
in fact
over at fox news dot com breaking just
moments ago
this is what happened when jim biden was
asked if he had any response to all the
corruption allegations
leveled against him and his family let's
take a look
mr biden hi do you care to answer some
questions
just wondering why did you involve joe
biden in your china deal
why did you and hunter biden want joe
biden to meet with tony b
what are you talking about i'm are you
mr jim biden
i wanted to ask you about the china deal
you don't want to comment sir
the money the wire transfers it's all
chronicled now
a serious scandal national security
diplomatic implications on a massive
scale
you wouldn't know it though if you watch
fake news cnn or
msdnc or you got your news from anyone
in the media mob
they didn't cover tucker's hour-long
interview with mr bob olinsky
they're not investigating his claims
they're not verifying the evidence
they are completely and totally ignoring
all of it
which is in and of itself a scandal
by the way as they ignored the johnson
and the grassley report
you know about the oligarchs about the
wire transfers
russia ukraine kazakhstan china
it's like an outright censorship of all
of this by big tech companies
twitter facebook the media mob and
tonight it is more obvious than ever
that very powerful forces the media mob
99 big tech companies almost
all of them the democratic socialist
party
the establishment never trumpers weak
establishment republicans
and the deep state now are all aligned
against this president
and his reelection now the only thing
that can stop that from happening is you
the american people and with at least 12
battleground states now in play
president trump is taking nothing and
nobody for granted
the president is traveling the country
at a rapid pace
earlier today he had two massive rallies
in arizona tomorrow he will be in
florida he will be in north carolina
and in six days let me tell you one
thing that nobody is telling you
anybody that is out there making
predictions they don't know what the
hell they're talking about
nobody has a crystal ball and by the way
don't believe anyone that is telling you
they know how this election will turn
out or donald trump only has a five
percent chance
you know what that is an effort to
deflate conservative
and republican votes your vote if you
believe this
is critical and everybody takes it
seriously
yes you can shock the world again and
the media mob will have to utter the
words
choke on them we can now project that
donald j
trump has been reelected the 45th
president of the united states
that can happen that is your power
you get to decide you are the ultimate
jury
and by the way you are the only thing
that is standing in the way
of the single most radical extreme
socialist
agenda and what would be an
administration in american history
joe biden may be at the top of the
democratic ticket but let's be honest
here
he's not exactly steering the ship he is
weak
he is frail he is cognitively struggling
he can barely get his words together he
seems totally at times completely out of
it like a half a corpse
that's being manipulated by the radical
socialists that are in charge
and there's geriatric joe along for the
ride in fact today
was a big day for joe biden this morning
he was driven to a local polling site
near his home in wilmington delaware
where he voted early delivered a couple
of remarks
and spent the rest of the afternoon
hiding again in his basement bunker
resting comfortably here we are six days
until an all-important presidential
election
joe biden took the day off again he's
not holding rallies he's not visiting
battleground states
you know barack obama is doing more
campaigning for joe biden and joe
biden's doing for joe biden
instead you got kamala harris she was
out on the campaign trail
rarely for her too and today while he
was taking his nap time in delaware
she was in the state of arizona hosting
a few events
with tiny little baby crowds very few
people
at this point even joe biden himself is
stating the obvious take a look
my name is joe biden i'm jill biden's
husband
and i'm commonless running mate
[Applause]
you all think i'm kidding don't you now
when they tell you who they are believe
them
senator harris is clearly in charge her
record
is to the left of bolshevik bernie
sanders and according to the
nonpartisan study she was ranked the
most
liberal senator in 2019.
that's right to the left of bernie a
devout socialist
she co-sponsored the green new deal she
also called for a ban on fracking and
fossil fuels
she wants to put a ban on plastic straws
she would like to limit the amount of
red
meat that americans are allowed to
consume and she is in favor of medicare
for all she co-sponsored that
including taxpayer-funded health
insurance for illegal immigrants
and by the way she is against private
health insurance plans
she supports of course packing the court
she promised to confiscate guns via
executive order
bypassing usurping the power of the
legislative branch of government
these are radical beliefs out of the
mainstream but that is your new
democratic socialist party
and pay attention because if some of the
polls are right
most people don't think joe biden can
even finish a first term
watch kamala harris more carefully for
example joe
biden's own website praises the green
new deal
as the crucial framework for battling
climate change
yesterday biden's own climate czar
congresswoman ocasio-cortez
had this to say about the increasingly
radical democratic party take a look
despite millions if not
billions of dollars of fossil fuel
money and lobbying and media campaigns
to smear the green new deal a majority
of people
still believe in this country that a
green new deal is the right way
forward now the main goal the green new
deal
is to put the oil and the gas industry
energy industry
out of business that means millions and
millions of high-paying career jobs
in the energy sector will be eliminated
our economy will be devastated
especially in places like pennsylvania
and ohio
and new mexico oklahoma texas and of
course
to accomplish this radical agenda
democrats could need to seize control of
the u.s supreme court
and during the democratic primary even
kamala
harris said that the democrats should be
willing to pack the courts
that would be the biggest power grab in
150 years in this country
multiple high-profile democrats are all
threatening to do that
or it's on the table including rom dead
fish
emanuel take a look minority leader
schumer is saying republicans will
regret her confirmation
do you think they will yes
well let me say yes i do think the
republicans will regret i regret not
only what they did here but what they
did at merrick garland at the end of uh
2016. uh they've twice now bent
the rules and cracked them and broken
them to uh
basically seize power in the supreme
court and politicize the supreme court
eddie's lying as usual because 29 times
in history during election years
well 29 presidents all made a nomination
to the supreme court
and by the way it's not just rom alone
following the confirmation of justice
amy coney barrett
by the way you'd be hard-pressed to find
any democrat
who isn't threatening to pack the courts
take a look
and the next time the american people
give democrats a majority in this
chamber
you will have forfeited the right
to tell us how to run that majority
my colleagues may regret this for a lot
longer
than they think how do we rebalance our
courts
yes the two supreme court cases that
have been stolen where these processes
that are just
wildly hypocritical have been used to
jam through partisan nominees
but we've got to look at our federal
courts as a whole rachel
should we expand the court well let's
take a look and see
but not and that relates to the nine
district courts maybe we need
more district courts as well
this election matters believe them
democrats will pack the courts
so their radical agenda will be left
totally and completely unchecked
there will be nothing to stop them from
stripping away your rights and
nationalizing
major sectors of the economy
confiscating private property
eliminating the second amendment
and of course joe and kamala if they get
their way there will be immediate
amnesty for
millions maybe up to 15 million illegal
immigrants
and you the american people they're
telling you this will be forced to pay
for the health insurance and other
government benefits
for anybody that crosses our borders
illegally